[Musik]
worauf du bastard noch meine kurz hallo
leute ich es wieder eure mal war und
heute habe ich zwei gäste erlitten
hatten angst dass es ein schönes des
spaniers zu machen müssen wir verhärtet
mit deinen kommentar am besten schon
angst habt ihr schon mal davon
naja so mehr video gemacht ja ich habe
mit vier stücken aus gezeigt ich hatte
ehrlich gesagt nicht mal mehr wieder
mache aber jetzt bin ich hier
du hast du dein private mehr ich auch
nicht okay dass ich find's gut dass es
ist so unglaublich warm gefahren in
diesen paar sekunden
das zweite papier das für hessen
das ist ein weiß crispy trittin habe ich
in amerika gekauft und das einst in new
york darauf zu klopfen
sein preis gutes spiel als er am arsch
weil ich würde mal denken dass das
wahrscheinlich um mir so werden aus
amerika ist
nein das ist heiß heute reicht das
wirklich raus ich dachte das muss meist
werden solltest du willst bist und nicht
jetzt tun sie herzlich
so schneidet man angst hat beim sc
mexiko
davon wird nur ein bisschen diskutier
ich würde sagen wir nehmen jetzt mal so
ein ding smart ist
[Musik]
wir probieren muss man ist so spatzen ja
nicht gleichzeitig rein weil wir einfach
nie lachen ich es ist das einzige was
man meinen es ist meine das wurde schon
vielfach kritisiert
volks christensen konnte mich mit euch
nochmal per facebook komplettieren
sollte dass jemand diese schwarzen kater
[Musik]
gebissen stehen denkt der denkt auch
gerade essen sowie prozent denkt ihr
bestehen die uns zu 70 prozent der
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
muss sofort durchschneiden
ich versuch's okay
fechter aus versuchen wollte ich
versuche
[Applaus]
gesicht gespuckt
für alle die auf gewalt an dieser stelle
ihr wart gerade in der verpackung das
hat sich gelohnt dass ihr aufgewacht
sein
ist das alles riskiert in der nähe ist
und dass man allerdings nicht klar da
freut sich jeder doch brauchen ich
glaube das hast du das ist überall
[Musik]
schließt die augen
[Gelächter]
was machst du jetzt auch beim nachhaltig
jetzt nutzen wir dir deine ohren
doch das habe ich gesagt
diese stäbchen
ich bin stehen gut nach mailand
gewechselt zudem mehr und wenn ja dann
treten die mit einem partner nicht
verstehst du morgen heißt erst so auf
das café ich habe heute schon die
waschmaschine angestellt du musst auch
mal was und immer aushalten haben du
dumme [ __ ]
[Applaus]
das ist jetzt der fall
yamaha auf gott hin abgeliefert
wir machen genau paar sachen diese stadt
sind
weinheim
[Musik]
das hab ich schon von vielen wo ihr
durstig gerade die faktor sich gelebt
[Musik]
während sein video geburt
ich töte dich deine familie
ich nehme dieses werk aus dass ich bis
auf dein grab die berger wenn ich jetzt
weiter
aufnehmende max noch zuwarten sich ja
weiter schreibt keinen kommentar robin
haase mehrkanal auf machen sollen wenn
sie nicht nennen
bis dann macht's gut schlafen schlecht
doch kelly vorbei wären bei den kleinen
videos gedreht hast du mich gehen
ich denk an dich